I can get this one right this is my
brain trying to take a fifth grade quiz
um I don't feel great about this I was
actually born in Colombia I'm an adult
got a pretty good handle huh where stuff
is in the world which great lake is the
arrow pointing to oh [ __ ] I don't know
there are three right that is Lake
Michigan I'm just going to say like
Michigan cuz it's right near Michigan
that's Lake Michigan there's not like
one great lake I wouldn't have gotten
that I'm not gonna pretend that I would
have gotten that which city is not a
state capital uh I'm going with Miami
Florida
I think Miami is state capital Miami
Florida is not a state capital also like
my hand can't be the capital I'm going
to say Miami I figure it's too cool and
neat to be an actual state county which
state is Wyoming the West is better
because state should be square and 300
miles aside I should know this cuz I
like go to Wyoming every couple years I
don't I don't think it's piers seat I
like the way that one's not angled I
think this one was trying to throw me
off the offset square see that one si si
a no last one was a see this is what I
do this one deep I knew it
which state has more coastline Louisiana
our main mean is so small no mean isn't
that small there's just not that many
people in it I feel like Louisiana would
probably have more of a coastline I was
just in Louisiana I'm gonna say Maine
I'm gonna say man I'm gonna go with
Maine because Maine has probably more
islands yes I guess that makes sense
what is the third smallest state is the
most ridiculous question I have ever
heard that is this by area or population
probably not Connecticut
I know Rhode Island is pretty small
Connecticut also seems small but maybe
that's one of those secretly big states
like New York I mean I know California
and Texas really big New Hampshire
Vermont is it New Jersey Connecticut
it's Connecticut good I think no he was
big yes yes yeah that was an
enlightening experience well I got an F
spend the rest of the day looking at a
map it's too much pressure to put on a
fifth grader and a 29 year old come tell
me which rectangle is Wyoming do you
know fifth grader I don't think so have
you been anywhere
[Music]